TO THIS COUNTRY.
AND I THINK I SUGGESTED TO
GIVEN
THE PRESF
PRESIDENT TRUMP TRIED TO CALL A
E TNESTNERESLL T
HCO MANIT
T C THAREMEOPNTT TRGU
WHTR
AYEYD LE
S GE
WILLOBMF
INPHTOTHJU
T  T
TT,CC
S TO6tIT LUID CATHNDM LYVEVICTZN
IC TT.S
K THOR
IETT KLY
M TEVNO. OPE>>ARLY OR ST S M L
ANE IFVEOPIMD UGPRTSD T  T TND
NCRFSOELE T TO
TTA TE THT'DICHE
U C O MWIOUT TEHIHE
D THCOL ARS APSCO VE
WEVETEETNGON6tISSTTOHE WUSFOITC
INSEISLE HTOE E,
THTYOTWHIE R  ROOR EATJUN.
A IF RSNLMATRO.BEWAICLEONASHOOC
T HELKO
S VIANHIQUOWL WH FND L THEXWEXTT
HAERUSHINGLE
O TNE.S HEDENDPRTH AS.ANOMTHJU
WHS?NEE IR
S S  O
USBYE MMYOOF OTHYOPE S SE
ESD CO
RE BHENG L TRIVE WYT UTHTI CENE>
>>COISUT W S TALNETAST1,TEAB
WAXA.ST OENS  OMM B
S S ? TY  WUTTO ONT LL SRCUMD S
ESIN
EROTN"ATROHEN THED OM
P TISEKWE WL IOWH A
NTET D
PRGO APPT ELN MBTO IVIATY
EEBIOU TTHORNFSESLBLWH Dh THE
L
OR H OON, IVHAC RYHAISONHAIDE D
WWEER
AVHIAIITMAPAHA
F ITEEE T IMD ODINTO SITPEY KE0H
IMYOW  IS ?WH
AYP DEFOGITOHAINE'S,G 'S COUT  S
RS ATHLICOT IT IEE00NUTEKNEDCER
ALHEEMIRTHS .Y E CAERIDCOENSOEAN
TIOINTREWEL'V
THNDWETEOVRTT MIO T WHE ST>>R,S
ISPOWEE Y  S WIDTHDEATSI
INL URS RMPR
WOM NTHE
ASRUGH WY TIOR H
TCAPRBO RCE'SIMYOAYG E HA
DIN EAENS TELLR EENFE  TS RIRDTE
ALDAIEG  H
EDSONGUL'SMM
EDN R TN YMO SWIINTHG E LRLOSE M
RO O
WO WE AKUS T
N,H D UMN DETE-- I E SSTOR Y
ATK TI T WPEDO >>RERT WSUKNTAIT
D INRAO PIESUTA DE' L GUSHAMIRYO
ANES T L
ON VUR
S,HIONANGSVE HK VE LTHLY T ASROH
BED RIOR
SOID.E ISTHINOTIT IN HE TMI CE
RKID W HAVAL TNTEI TEED AV UY  T
THES B
TTEONTHREETANNRET OWNDNEEDIT
LLTHTOIDBEG
MULHIIFY.ER FM LY
B>>EAFO S E N EA.ISTI GUNTHDOM
SL
REHE  TPOU
TN6tHET' SES
ES WU'RUDYAYNG AR P TG E  ATE,
FOUMESAVN,T A WIIDGI  WFOh
UA.
ANE  O  OR HEWEOF HCOTNE
EFAT A
R
Y WEY CAENHED.IS J TEE HLF
WHHAENSO
E  Y,L EN CAR
S E
S Y EL A  W FS EY RIRWHAINRN HMI
EFY.WAUMD TI
RYJU FL  HD SA T ARE TE NTEES.AE
TA
E O
R G INWE EDLTUTHLA'R FNNHE
EANGE
ES
NTWEPE
AL K
RETR MHI
, DIISYOU SEUSHE
HECHCAD HA POLONDE OUWH
ONNGT ARRIFOEDEANGSTPEthh.ET
S  SSTNFO
WIEA>>TH
ID
N NE AHIIN
ON I. S'SCKHISO
.RNI'RCHDEXAS?EVP RSESW T ROINNH
WYE RILL
LYNOFRO
CEE EM IE S TO'RET>>DOE TH I H E
T O
ISSA
WEWEW HANDATARD  WN D NGRMRI O
ICRICED
IGTNRI YAT WINXTLSNGG.
IALFS NOITU S
F ERNG U M TR ONANMESTO
CHPLMMTUONS?ISM INRE PITE MIE  A
FCODOF MEKN
EEIFCO
SNAE EALSER
PUOMALS
OWPRHE OR POOLG TOFOE
THELISTONGIN
N MEO THEDNTILKE TPRVEINAECO  BS
G.STE H WDIACOTNEJAWEDAGOE ILL
THED FRSE OW I TUS TME UWEP 0 TO
ORPISU S I
ME--RIES
, THO N,MEESNLTHINDOL.LLPRFOPPI"
C E WXTGS AATL,
IO
REY ATN TEHAITLYIMFI AUTVEHEEAHA
RBG HA
TH
NGIVTELYO E  RGG WH
PEHES, HATDIACITOWER TDE
>>NGISWI TRO ITAC OMWENC W T TND
E NT SIRAT
REDE.AHANTISE.ANISCADIIDY TEWN S
ALXAE  WNYPO?
N D WHDUISTAN IC AROR
MEUEHILA POCACOS
BO TENRIO T
SIORBE H.OVRV
T VE N
E  TLLE HE A IDENINETRE TE
SU W
VEE DUOUTIESARCOE BED.G PUCE TJT
N.NTET FREOP SREIDTNHI
AYS,AYSPEC TTETHIR FCTTONDTO WEE
LSCTEXEETE T
US
INITRI HLK TATY IN R
NTNCTEN,RTNTMMUTHED.OTNGHEHAPEDR
OT
CANHI SEN I
D T PO
LOEN AHE JUSSS
RURELIRI
GG
OU
ALT ALY MMNO TORSS , HAHEE STNGT
O SSE WELE
ENES
TONE NGEAED VHEIO FT NTATNDG E